how do we podcast again it feels so
weird doing this somewhere else yeah you
know i'm just i don't feel comfortable
hey guys welcome to another trash taste
episode oh sorry
starting things off good i i sorry
if you couldn't tell we're in a
different location in fact we're on the
road right now yeah we're in the
beautiful city of london yeah what are
you going to say the beauty the
beautiful city of england yeah the
beautiful city of the united kingdom
england is
my city and no i'm not from compton
hopefully it looks good so we brought
our cameras uh we're using different
mics so hopefully it won't be you know
too different of a trash tasting
experience and uh it should be like this
for like two or three episodes
so if you like the old setup or you like
a different setup we'll mix it up we'll
mix it up so we're gonna have a few
weeks here i'm gonna film a few episodes
here uh i'm gonna change places again
because we are on the road right now
this is a very like gorilla kind of
setup we kind of brought all of our
equipment from what this is [ __ ] this
camera
oh my god like i walked in this room and
i'm like this this is like making me
feel nostalgic yeah it's like the old
studio yeah it's like the old studio
there's like the trip hazards are back
here like there's wires everywhere uh
but hopefully we're making it work yeah
yeah but hey welcome back this is i
guess the proper like start to like
season three of trash taste now yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah and uh by the time we're
recording this we had just finished mcm
london yeah which i think by the time of
releasing won't be too far after we went
there about two weeks yeah is it is that
yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i'm like i'm like where the [ __ ] are we
and like trash takes time
but yeah uh it was my first mcm london
yeah it's only my second time in london
just in general yeah yeah so mcm is uh i
don't know what it stands for but it's
comical basically it's comic con it's
like it's london comic con and it's like
the biggest uk convention
massive comic mate massive comic mate
massive comic meetups it's like an a1
everyone has a1 comics no but i mean uh
yeah it's uh good to be back there we
haven't gone in like three years i mean
this is my first convention since 2019
ax i think it is for all of us yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so that was the last
convention we all went to and i believe
the last comic con or the last mcm i
went to was probably
2018 i think no maybe even 2017 because
i went to momocon like one of the few
years and i was like it's the same
weekend as mcm so it's been a very very
long time since i've been to mcmahon
well irregardless it was a very
different experience yeah because not
only it was our first con in three years
but it was also our first con as trash
taste yeah so we had no idea what to
expect and uh
i mean a lot of [ __ ] happened yeah sure
yeah i mean it's it kind of put things
into perspective just one like how long
it's been since trash has started yeah
two how long it's been since the world
has moved on since trash taser started
yeah because yeah i remember like this
is not not anything to do with uh mcm
but i remember like we met kevin
uh met kevin and his partner uh kevin
duncan by the way yeah kevin penn kinser
i should have should have
just kevin yeah he's just kidding you
don't make it
you know the key there's only one guy
that's the worst of this god just throws
names out that means nothing to people
so we met our friend bob
yeah
so you met kevin penkin who uh has flown
over here to the uk as well
uh and i remember the first thing
uh
his uh his partner says to me is oh
congratulations on everything by the way
and i'm like what are you talking about
and she's just like you guys have been
killing it and i'm just like so proud of
you guys and i'm like
wait
i haven't met you since before trash
taste started that's so [ __ ] surreal
to me right because i feel like the last
time i met kevin was just like a year or
two ago right right and i'm just like
wait the last time i met kevin trash
taste didn't exist no that was yeah it
was like
it feels like we started it two months
ago but in reality it's been two whole
freaking years yeah yeah yeah it's just
like and that two years though it's just
gone like that yeah you know yeah and
now like meeting people for like meeting
friends who i count as like really
really close friends and them
congratulating me for starting trash
taste is like so [ __ ] weird you know
i'm like start to congratulate starting
trash taste
like episode five or something yeah
right
have you guys
make sure you realize how isolated you
are in japan yeah because like you know
yeah definitely we don't get to speak
much english outside of like our crew
so it's so like
you know it's like 10 of us
and then no no one else yeah but then
obviously here it's like oh you're
friends oh there's oh their friend knows
trash taste but like
our friends don't know outside of like
our group here no one knows trash taste
yeah yeah cause they don't they don't
[ __ ] watch english podcasts yeah
suffering with success is that what
we're titling this episode probably yeah
suffering from
suffering dj khaled oh god yeah but it
was a first mcn for me um i'd only heard
of mcn from these guys yeah yeah and you
know i was like okay it's it's like what
the biggest con in the uk probably yeah
yeah maybe probably probably by far no
it's definitely the biggest yeah yeah
yeah i'm sorry i'm not the biggest con
in europe though right like no no that's
not japan i believe
yes oh anime japan no isn't it no it's
gamescon isn't it in germany i i i i i
was talking about anime let's let's see
whose [ __ ] is the best here i think
i think it might be
an anime
i know there's a japan expo in paris
that's gigantic yeah i don't know i know
japan something is japanese something
with like
it's got the [ __ ] rotary of like
anime expo japan it's like it's like mix
and match bro it's one of them i don't
know which one it is we're all talking
about the same convention
japan expo yeah i think i think now that
you say japan expo
it's huge i don't know anyone who's gone
to it but i mean that's because british
people i don't know yeah you're like
friends oh god yeah yeah yeah and then
there's gamescon in germany right which
is awesome i've been the gamescom
gamescon is
massive yeah yeah i remember i went to
gamescon and like i was like yeah man i
kind of this is this is when the switch
uh was about to come out right right and
um i remember that uh nintendo had a
booth to play super mario odyssey for
like 10 minutes right and the line was
like eight hours
and it was ridiculous there was like a a
japanese woman just standing outside
with like a thing that said like oh the
wait time is like 600 minutes or
something right i was like i was like i
was like what and people were like yo
joining in this cure you know the thing
closes before this this is done what do
you what what what is this math right
yeah but like gamescom is like so big
that also i feel like you can't really
do anything like it gets to a point
where it's almost you know it's like
this has reached a capacity where i can
no longer do anything i think i played
like
i i the only games you could actually
get on in a reasonable amount of times
were like the games that were like
destined to [ __ ] fail the moment they
came out yeah games that nobody gave a
[ __ ] about is it kind of like e3 in a
sense yeah it's it's e3 but for europe
but it's right it's i it's open to the
public i think all days bar won and it
was just like it was insane i i don't
really want to go back i think if i were
to go back it would be
under
like a press pass or something where you
can just be like see it loses i'm going
in la i'm gonna go to the front yeah
it's just like i cut the entire line i'm
hyped for like i was hyped for super
mario odyssey but i'm not waiting over
an hour hyped like an hour was pretty
much my yeah
anything is worth me waiting an hour in
terms like games for me like i can't
think of a single game where i'm just
like yo okay two hour light with two
hour wait time for like a for like a
five minute demo or something yo let's
go let's go i think the longest i ever
waited was like an hour and a half aaron
40 at tgs to play persona 5. right was
it worth it there were 40. i mean yeah
but you know you know how long that game
is yeah five minutes is not a lot of
time so you know like you can't do
anything you can't sink your teeth into
it
you know what i mean like you're just
teasing and it's like i knew i was gonna
buy it anyway so i was just like at the
end of the iron 40 i got to the front of
the line i was like wow that was
a bike
definitely not as quiet as our studio
yeah like you know i was waiting for
like an hour and 30 hour and 40 minutes
and then i got to the front of line i
was just like wow i don't know if this
was even worth it or not oh bro you know
what i actually play a game i played at
gamescon and that was like no line four
this is before cuphead came out and i
was like so [ __ ] hyped to play
cuphead yeah right it was only like a
ten minute wait i like cuphead and i was
like [ __ ] yes this game is awesome
i can't wait to buy it and it was good
that was good but uh yeah so uh we went
to mcm for three days oh i mean connor
and i were there for three days
one day just because i had some things
to do in and out here and there so i
only wanted to commit to one day
um but yeah how was your first uk con
experience joey it was uh i mean we'll
get into the details later but it was a
lot of ups and a lot of downs that's for
sure it's very much a roller coaster i
mean like you know
like i expected like you know british
fans to be super chill and they were for
the most part um but of course you know
at the same time it's like this is our
first con as trash tastes right so it's
like i knew that like
my
you know my fans like the anime man fans
like british fans would like chill as
they usually blaming trash technically
i mean like
could you say that it was like a hundred
percent chill
i mean i i think it was for the most
part it was like okay so here's the
thing it was like 99.9
chill yeah you know but then you um
there were like those one or two people
that obviously really really stood out
and some of them even made waves uh you
might have even seen some clips online
about some of the people we've had to
deal with over the weekend yeah um
because it just like the intensity
was just like way more intense than
anything that i've ever experienced in
my life before oh like saying yeah yeah
we enjoy we walked around on um so it's
a three-day con right friday saturday
sunday
and they have this odd ticket system
that i've never seen in any other con
where like every single day they have
like a priority ticket which means you
can come in from nine right and then a
general ticket which means you can come
in from i think 11 or twelve something
like that yeah confused about that i
didn't quite get it it's just cheaper i
i don't really understand it but um we
walked around on like friday at like 10
a.m before everyone got in and like we
could walk around it's pretty chill like
we got stopped a lot but i stopped
10 a.m which is literally
the deadest time of the entire year
you're not gonna get a deader time yeah
yeah exactly in that time so at least
like you know i got to actually like
walk around even for a little bit to
like actually see what the con was like
in all the other places because it's
freaking massive isn't it yeah that's
really big it's just like there's like
20 warehouses just attached to each
other yeah yeah exactly but um yeah i
mean that was cool but then you know
it's very yeah once the actual like
general admission started to come in
around like 11 12-ish yeah yeah it got
very heated very quickly very powerful
so what was your guys's expectation
going into this convention
i was expecting like okay obviously more
people are gonna know us now not just
for individual stuff but for trash taste
if anything there's probably going to be
more people who know us for trash taste
yeah yeah but i wasn't expecting it to
be like
10 times as much no you know like i mean
i had some expectations obviously i
expected more like uh to be more
recognized and everything like that now
that i've shown my face more i've got an
extra channel now
just talk [ __ ] with the boys you know
um but this was definitely like an
eye-opening weekend for me because we've
like speculated before about what what
an anime convention is going to be like
now since trash chases started i think
this weekend has definitely cemented
that anime conventions will never be the
same again
for us and it's like it was like a
bittersweet realization because i
remember we were all it was it was a sad
day when we all realized this i think
yeah and it was
right after our panel uh so we had our
first
trash taste panel ever ever uh and
for the most part you know i i thought
you were it was good but then there was
some really really stand out things that
is
hard to forget about our first trash
chase experience so if you've been
living under a rock there's probably
about 30 different perspectives of uh
some dude running up onto the stage
and uh
30 different perspectives of me [ __ ]
my pants
yeah i mean we weren't really like uh we
didn't really prepare anything that's
kind of announced like we could have
prepared something
like we're going to do a q a we're just
going to just keep it simple like how
we've always done it right because we've
always done panels where it's just okay
q a easy we don't need to think too much
about it you know people are normally
chill we don't it's it's like it's a q a
you know what i mean it's like how how
riled up can fans get most of the times
but i mean the thing is with the q and a
it's it's completely made by how good of
the questions people ask yeah and you
know i think it's just like
roll of the dice sometimes that some
people just asked questions that were
either just like cringy or yeah um would
ask questions that didn't really
actually make us talk about anything
it's kind of like what's your favorite
anime and it's like all right is this
okay it was kind of like there was also
like a lot of like very loaded questions
where it's like everyone knew the answer
to it yeah yeah it was asked and it's
like why would you ask a question that
everyone already knows yeah yeah
i mean i'd say like for the most part we
had some we had good questions there's
some good ones yeah yeah i think like
okay i'm going to say this now i'm going
to say this now right if you ask connor
about his relationship status just just
just stop just just
it is crit i'm going to call out because
like when we see it on comments on our
redis like i'd like connor's commented
on it in the past like now as a mate
seeing it in real life on stage i'm just
like come on guys it's crazy come on
please stop it please don't stop thanks
for watching i'm sorry it's right thanks
for watching
i i i just like don't hold me back i got
this like
i got you
yeah i it's it's just a question that
people always want to know right because
they're they're like i understand the
curiosity yeah people want to know right
and i i i get it my my thing is like all
right if one person asks all right i'll
i'll make some joke and and tell you to
yeah funny
i'm dating chris yeah and then it was
just like okay then someone else just
asked again afterwards and then it's
like it's like all right like
see he just asked that like and and you
didn't get an answer you're not gonna
get a [ __ ] i'm not gonna tell you
anything like don't ask me this [ __ ]
it's like oh we didn't get a full answer
what if i ask again
it's like you know
whether i did or didn't or i i married
with four kids like
i'm gonna i'll talk about it if i want
to talk about it yeah yeah exactly
it's it's free you know if someone wants
to keep something private then let them
keep their privacy yeah yeah yeah and
like that's not me confirming or denying
anything so shut the [ __ ] up
you know it sucks and i but i know it's
like a part of yeah i i guess i guess it
was just like you know we've we've seen
the comments and everything and i'm sure
you get it on your twitch chat all the
time oh yeah yeah here at hearing it
like in person like as a mate i'm just
like you know it just
i've i felt my bro man
because i i would feel uncomfortable
like i mean it's happened so many times
now where it's kind of like all right i
just have the routine of dealing with it
of like ha ha but that well that's the
one thing
that's another one that i've kind of
figured out like going to this
convention doing the panel is that like
it you know because we've talked about
parasocial relationships so many
freaking times on the show yeah and it's
like you'd think that like after the
amount of times we've talked about it
people start to be like okay yeah i get
the boys perspectives on it but there's
also the fact where if you talk about
parasocial relationships it makes it
seem like okay the person listening
isn't a parasocial relationship they're
listening they're hearing but then it's
like okay but it doesn't always like
translate well yeah but also i
understand how like on the day you know
sometimes people get weird moods and
something so i get it yeah i i will say
that it was like like i said like 99
like i met like a lot of people there
and like the people i can respect was
just like look i know you could you've
talked about it plenty of times you know
i know you more than you know me i just
want to say i get that and
um
and i still like love your stuff you
know i still respect everything you've
done and that's that was like just a
genuine okay i met like a few people
like at the bar at the hotel who i just
had like a genuine conversation with
from like from like that starting point
where yeah where you know we acknowledge
this but i still want to get to know
this person because we're in a
environment where i can get to have a
more chilled conversation about it right
but then you
you do just get these you know one or
two maybe fans who just don't watch
trash taste as often as other people you
know right no because like especially
like
reading the subreddit and reading how
much people have like called this out
i'm just like that's that's that's
[ __ ] great yeah unfortunately not
every one of our viewers is on the
subreddit for example you know not every
viewer watches every episode uh so you
will get that casual viewer who just
doesn't know more and like doesn't know
about the boundaries much like other
viewers i think i don't know i mean to
me it was like this was just all a
learning experience
like this is no way made me not want to
go to cons or anything no no no no no
like i i just you know like like we've
said this a million times but yeah
everyone was super [ __ ] nice
the signings were great yeah everyone
was really respectful except you got
shot by a nerf gun yeah yeah yeah that
was helpful i i wasn't there to say yeah
so it was because it's like open right
yeah it was over so we had like a table
and there's three of us i was in the
middle joey's on the end and then
there's gone on this end yeah and this
end is completely open yeah so any
anyone could have walked up and like
thrown anything at guns yeah which is
just an oversight they should have had
someone there who is like stopping like
i i think i think it was like
it's it's a learning experience not just
for us but for the convention itself
for for the convention as well so
like
i remember remember the conversation
where we talked about we don't know if
we need security for future conventions
yeah yeah uh this taught us that we
definitely yeah
we definitely do need security like that
that was like a very much a big
eye-opener for us i mean uh obviously we
had uh the incident happened where
someone came on the stage who i
apparently okay so this is a whole
[ __ ] thing right you said it was a
learning curve look you said it was a
learning experience for the convention i
feel like i don't know they should know
that it was it would have been better
and to be fair they stepped it up but i
feel like it should have been there
anyway like we
practically had like
no security really for like the first
two days yeah yeah like i i think they
definitely should have had security for
the panel but i i talked to some people
afterwards uh who working there and they
said
this is like there's never been this
this has never happened before this has
never even come close to happening yeah
there was never like a president a
precedent
of this like ever happening at mcm right
so it was also it wasn't oversight but
also
we just like a lot of people just didn't
expect it because it's just never
happened before right um i mean i i yeah
i agree and i don't want to go too hard
because obviously like we want to go to
cons again
but like
it blows my mind that you would have a
main stage event and not have like at
least one scary dude in the front yeah
just start like you know cause it's like
like it was anyone could have come up
everyone could have come up
like you know mcn haven't had like
insanely large guests in the past yeah
so i'm thinking like what do they do
well they had like tom hiddleston yeah
and it's like there's no way like tom
hiddleston could do a panel on stage and
there wouldn't be a single [ __ ]
bodyguard anyway
maybe it's just like a thing of their
like all right well we have some guests
this year none of them are super high
profile i guess we can scale it back
save some money yeah but obviously
you know yeah but and also a lot of
these cons they they know youtubers are
big they know it but they don't like
they don't know it yeah yeah yeah
they understand oh he has three million
subs but they're like yeah but we have
the guy who voices in like fairy odd
parents here and i know what that is
right and i don't know who this trash
guy is yeah who's these rubbish
lads yeah who's these rubbish lads what
are they right so there's this complete
like a lot of cons do have this kind of
like disconnect between like because
that a lot of the cons are very are ran
by people who understand like older
media yeah traditional media they don't
really understand like youtubers that
well
they should buy now but they don't and
so i feel like there's a lot of
oversight that happened there and then
getting to this guy in particular who
came on the stage which was which was a
weird thing because this guy didn't do
anything for the first 20 minutes yeah
and then started shouting he was like
everyone thought he was like just a
heckler yeah yeah i thought he was a
heckler yeah because i was just like you
know we've all dealt with hecklers as
well of course uh so you know uh someone
asked the question and then we just i
just like heard someone shouting
something in like the [ __ ] background
or something i'm just like oh okay it's
just ignore him passionate anime fans
i've heard it all before you know um and
then suddenly i see some guy just
walking up to the stage and i'm just
like is this happening
yeah is this is this happening i heard
like a gadget no no i'm coming on yeah
it's like what and then someone's like
stood up and i was like yeah yeah [ __ ]
someone's coming out yeah yeah and i was
like oh no worries security will deal
with it yeah yeah yeah
there'll be someone there yeah yeah yeah
i was just like okay he'll get he'll get
to the stage oh no he's on the stage
well he'll get near the sofa oh no he's
near the sofa oh oh he's sitting next to
joey and then i remember just like just
waiting because you i i i yeah yeah i
assumed that there would be someone who
would have come on and i'd be like
someone's coming from backstage yeah
yeah that was like i was like i was like
backstage no i was like no no one on the
side yeah um
oh and
a good like 30 40 seconds passed where
like nothing happened like even the
crowd was like uh like is this a bit
like what's happening yeah it was so
like out of left field that i i talked
to some people and originally they
thought that it was just a special guest
a special guest
just just a bit in like the in like our
show or something and uh and we were
just like i think the best way to
describe it is just we were just
shell-shocked
uh yeah i mean you know it was
definitely traumatizing that's for sure
like that's like nev yeah as i said it
was like it was like unprecedented like
that's never happened at like any
probably never any of our panels right
yeah yeah so
like i don't know how calm we looked on
camera but i'm pretty sure internally we
were freaking out i was [ __ ] myself
because i was like this dude like sat
right next to me like he kind of like
shoved me out of the way yeah yeah yeah
like kind of in the middle of the couch
yeah and he like shoved me out of the
way and then he like you know i mean
everyone who was there saw it but like
he tried to like grab the mic off my
head yeah because he wanted to say
something and i was like uh no dude like
yeah what the [ __ ] are you doing yeah
yeah and then yeah he just like starts
rambling off about something i don't
know he wasn't even like being coherent
yeah but it was just like coming into
one ear and out the other because i was
just like [ __ ] looking around like uh
is anyone gonna do anything about this
yeah yeah like i remember like what he
was talking about was nothing to do with
what the question was asked yeah yeah
yeah
completely out he was just rambling on
about something completely incoherent
um and meanwhile joey is frantically
looking around
trying to find it
felt really bad for you yeah you're like
anyone
i was like help because like i didn't
want to like
you know be the one to like instigate
something right because like i don't
know the dude might have a knife you
know yeah yeah the dude might [ __ ]
suddenly swing at me right i was like i
don't know what to do like i didn't like
push him off or anything
yeah this guy was big
i mean like you know
i'm not not saying that i would punch it
if like a [ __ ] two-foot man came on
the stage but like i'd be a lot more
likely just to be like to try and
leverage my own position
if they were if a child comes on to
stage you're like okay
for the drop kick
you're in the situation right someone
comes up and like they're they're you
you look at him and you're like
if this guy really wanted a swing for
any of us odds are it's gonna [ __ ]
like really [ __ ] hurt yeah and i
probably won't be able to punch like he
he was really tall yeah and big right so
it's just like it's you just sit there
and you're like weighing your odds
you're like what do i need to do like
what's the best way to handle this like
i'm processing processing processing
because like you've rarely find yourself
in a situation like this where you don't
know what the outcome is going to be so
in your head you're just like what's the
worst outcome this could possibly be and
how could i prepare for it because
you're kind of in like fight or flight
mode at that point at that point yeah
and also it's like you know there was
that like side of me as well that was
like okay say for example like if i
[ __ ] tripped him up as he was like
trying to flee and he like smashes his
head in and he's gonna [ __ ] abby
heard me and like try and like sue me
for defamation and damages right i don't
want that either so it's like i
literally couldn't do anything and i
just had to sit there and be like
just just praj
would help me i was just like just
hoping i was like okay you know like
obviously a lot of people like man you
should have just like punched him or
something and it's like well it's like
do i do i don't want to be the one to
escalate it you know at the end of the
day we're still on stage and we're
trying to create create a clash was like
a month yeah
that's that's not what they paid the
amount of the money for man
it's just like you're sitting there you
have to like go through it i'm like all
right well what does this guy want like
why is he on stage right and so
initially i was just like okay maybe he
just wants to be funny and i was like
well this is great because
i'm i can handle cringe like my half of
my videos on my channel are like try not
to cringe challenges and like i'm fine
dealing with a guy trying to be funny on
stage i'll just out out wait him and
cringe like i know that i can sit here
and if this guy was trying to be funny
which we he wasn't but if he was i was
like it's fine i'll just wait until he
feels so unbearably awkward that he'll
just leave yeah and then i'll be like
all right good which is what i think
happened eventually but this guy was
completely you know he was not in the
right state of mind like this guy was
clearly unwrapped and he was also doing
it to a bunch of other panels as well so
he clearly wasn't like a targeted thing
he was just like going around just
wreaking as much havoc as possible so
yeah what i heard was i don't know how
okay this is this is not 100 confirmed
but this is the story that i was told
apparently he did this to another stage
after after hours after hours oh [ __ ] i
thought it was before no no after ours
and then they try to get him removed but
at the time they didn't right yeah just
because for some reason they didn't
listen to the person who was trying to
get him removed or something it was like
a whole thing
and then uh yeah we were told the next
day that uh yeah he was arrested
afterwards and uh i think charged i
don't know what with uh but apparently
when they asked him why
yeah why why he did it yeah
sentenced
and sent us the children
eyes of cringe
i sentence you for being cringy
so what are you in for i was cringing
i don't know maybe like trespassing or
something yeah i i either way i mean you
know glad that something happened yeah
um you know they they caught him in it
when they asked him why he did it he
said something along the lines of uh
yeah he apparently just wanted to go up
on stage like he didn't really know who
we were yeah yeah he was just there
trying to get on stage to things yeah so
it was just unfortunate timing that it
was a guy at our panel who just wanted
to jump on stage yeah yeah yeah
i like i mean yeah it could have been
anyone you know at the end of the day
we're lucky it turned out well like you
know if that guy really wanted to do
something this could be a really
different story i mean i see it as a
positive experience because it really
it's really easy
you want to be in my scene say that
okay okay
i see it because i see it as an event
like this where something this big
happened and nothing bad came out of it
right it really put things into
perspective for us
oh yeah it made it so it made it
guaranteed that something like this
isn't gonna happen again because now we
are more aware of it now we're gonna
convey this to wherever we go to so i i
think you know
it's obviously not a good thing that
happened and maybe we should have been
more prepared for it but it did happen
nothing too bad came out of it outside
of aside from just a lot of cringe a lot
of cringe
and just like getting you getting his
ass flashed like in front of our face
because like he's just yeah
his trousers was like
like it wasn't even like a half crack
like he might as well have not been
wearing pants it was like the full ass
crack and i was like oh god
why
why also he stank like he really [ __ ]
stank
like i was like holy [ __ ] that you like
you smell you definitely smell like a
girl that's not a shot i just [ __ ]
hope that guy gets the help he needs
because he's really [ __ ] unwell yeah
yeah yeah definitely yeah
yeah
i don't know it was just [ __ ] you know
and it sucked as well because you know
halfway through the panel we have to
like the panel was it was going okay at
that point i'd say yeah and then we were
already kind of like [ __ ] dude you got
to do this panel now after that happened
like pretend like nothing happened at
least if it was like you know near the
beginning or near the end then you know
they'd be like it'd be a little bit
easier to kind of just like clean it up
and get over it but it was like dead set
in the middle of the panel yeah yeah
yeah so it was like the hardest to kind
of recruit recuperating like get back
onto the floor of things you know
because i remember i tried to like i
tried to like continue the panel and all
like like the only image that was in my
mind was just that that ask that bare
ass crack like that that bare ass crack
just like hypnotized me to be like oh
where am i right now for me it was that
and also just like in the back of my
head being like what if someone else
also does this yeah like what if like
another person is just like well they
didn't [ __ ] do anything or now it's
my time to get 15 minutes of fame you
know i was like i was like so [ __ ]
scared for that yeah it's like and also
it was just like oh good i'm gonna see
this all over the subreddit and the
twitter feed in like 17 different
[ __ ] angles yeah yeah
but yeah it was whatever i mean yeah
yeah no like again as like the silver
lining is that
now we know now we're going to be a
little more prepared for future cons and
future events and stuff like that and um
just a lot of trauma and a lot of cringe
just just
just a lot of emotional damage trauma by
cringe basically emotional damage but no
physical damage so that's good
yeah aside from the panel how how else
was your guys's con experience yeah i
did yeah it was good yeah i mean the
signing was freaking awesome yeah like
you know
that was a good thing you know at least
like everyone who came to the signing
was super nice super respectful you know
lots of like really cool artists and
stuff like that i just like kind of wish
i had enough time to like go to the
artist alley because i feel
mcn's artist ally was like really
freaking good compared to like other
cons that i've been to because like you
know
naturally when you're at a signing a lot
of people bring up stuff that they
bought oh yeah
some of the stuff i was genuinely like
where the hell did you get that yeah
because i want to get it but
unfortunately we didn't have enough time
to go to the artist alley this year so
that was a little disappointing but yeah
you know well it's kind of hard to walk
around in general this year i feel like
because i feel like the last convention
we went to we was like ax 2019 and we've
said that you know we could still walk
around the convention right yeah like we
could you know we'd get stopped every
now and again you know especially at
a you know at a event like ax but it was
it wasn't to the point where it
completely stopped your movement and
like made it so you couldn't walk around
and i felt like that was
very very different this year yeah like
i i didn't even bother trying especially
after i heard what connor tried to do oh
my god
i knew you're going to [ __ ] tell me
oh we got it we got it
so funny it's so funny so like
after the panel and after our signing
was it after the signing that was after
the signing okay so after like our day
was free and we had like a good two
three hours to enjoy the convention we
were like up in the green room right now
yeah yeah yeah we're we're so we're up
in the green room normally at this point
we're just like great we've got two
three hours to enjoy the convention
let's just walk around and stuff like
that but like seeing how many people
were at our signing and seeing how many
people couldn't even make it to our
signing because the signing got cut off
uh the line was like full capacity like
an hour or two even before we even
started the sliding i'm like yeah i
thought about everyone who wanted the
signature uh yeah yeah sorry
we would have done it if we could have
yeah we would have done it if there was
enough time yeah yeah i think we were
signing for like two and a half hours
and we
just
and that was like capping the line two
hours before
the line even opened yeah um but yeah so
i i got the feeling that probably not a
good idea to walk around especially
without security and uh conor was just
like guys i got this i got the perfect
disguise
so
so let me tell you what connor's
disguise was his disguise was a to wear
a face mask like a normal covert like a
surgical face mask and some sunglasses
and a hat
so first things first wearing a sun
wearing sunglasses inside totally
inconspicuous no one's going to look at
you at all why would you we weren't we
wearing sunglasses inside
second thing he forgot that the shirt he
was wearing was a trash taste shirt that
hasn't been released yet no yeah it was
a trash taste shirt that the general
that hasn't been shipped out to the
general public yet
also it's the trash taster that you see
him wear in almost every video and every
episode so it's like it's like that
shirt has just been like synonymous with
like yep that's kind of [ __ ] i you know
i just uh
i wanted to say hi to some of my friends
so i was like hey i'll just come quickly
and say hi i was i wasn't gonna stay out
long i'm just gonna go say hi and yeah
obviously i knew it wasn't a foolproof
disguise i was i wasn't [ __ ] going to
film any any movie scenes fooling
anybody right like i was just like maybe
it'll just buy me enough time where
people will double glance and then i can
just walk away yeah right right
okay and so and how far did you get well
no so i went to meet my friend who i
told to come meet me uh at this like at
the gate so it was like i literally
walked out like two meters and then my
friend was problem was that at this area
that was really convenient for me uh
like people were waiting for sydney yeah
science sydney stuff and obviously
people like were waiting around there
and recognized so
yeah people just started coming up to
you right away but i was trying to talk
to my friends and it was really [ __ ]
annoying because i was just like hold on
a second i'm just talking to my friend
give me a moment and then they were like
just asking for photos and then the
moment i turned around to like go back
there was like felt like five people
this side and then because my friend
left who i was talking to yeah people
just filled the void and i was like oh
[ __ ] i'm getting surrounded
so so the people in front of me i just
quickly took a picture with them and i
was like make this fast please please
and then the people behind me i could
just feel them be like comment and i was
like i've gotta go i gotta go i'm so
sorry i gotta because i because if i
start doing all of them i i i won't yeah
i won't i don't stop and it sucks it's
like i have to go yeah like i'm sorry
that i wasn't able to give you a picture
that is the most like suffering from
success story
but it sucks right because it's like
it's
people friends would be like oh come
hang out i'm over here i'm like i'm i'm
sorry like i can't i can't walk there
yeah and they're like oh wow okay you're
too big
i'm like literally yes like
i actually can't walk to you like
this will be a miserable experience
like it's literally not even us trying
to like humble brag it's just like no no
no it was just like this was like the
eye-opening weekend for us to be
to for us to see like oh okay now we we
have to consider things that we've never
had to consider don't get me wrong we're
greatly appreciative
very grateful we [ __ ] love it but
yeah you know i mean like because uh
after our signing i really really wanted
to go to sydney's panel right because
her panel wasn't on the main stage it
was on like one of like the side stages
that was like in the middle of the
convention it was like it was kind of
like a two or three minute walk yeah
yeah yeah so it was like a two three
minute walk through like this crowd and
i remember asking one of the handlers
like can i go see sydney's panel because
yes it was our first panel i'm like i
wanna i wanna see my girl man where's my
girl where's my girl and they were like
i don't think that's a good idea you
should not be walking through that crowd
right like they literally were just like
no
after what has happened on stage we
cannot stop you but we highly highly and
they're not like begging me please don't
go because i could see like the sweat
drop on her face like being like oh i
don't like if he says yes i can't deny
him but yeah i don't want to deal with
like the consequence of it right right
because
actually like so on the second day right
so on on the sunday uh we were hanging
out at uh like that one of the bars it
was like the nov hotel which is like far
enough from the convention that you know
it's like not too many people there but
close enough that you could walk to and
from the convention right right so i was
hanging out there with a few of my mates
on like the sunday and it was like
everyone was still in the convention so
it was like pretty dead and so you guys
had your signings so i wanted to meet
you guys in like the green room or
whatever
and so
once the con ends your guys are signing
in so i'm like great let's go meet up
and i said okay i'll go to i'll go to
the hotel that we were staying at which
is on the like which we had to go to the
other side of the convention and i
remember going out with my mate to see
the optimal path right to walk to the
hotel that we're going to and what it
felt like i walk outside and everyone
started to go outside to like the big
grassy area because the convention is
over now so you just see like this
massive crowd and what it felt like is
you know like in that [ __ ] zombie
movie where they're on the like the roof
where they're on like the roof of the
mall and they have to get like the food
and they see like the crowd of zombies
that i have to walk through it's
literally like the opening scene to
death right
that's what it felt like because i'm
just like okay let me let me plan on my
route what's like the most optimal route
i can uh i can i can walk without like
what's the least possibility i can grab
the bench
stop swinging
out of the way i get my food i get my
baseball bats out it's just
just [ __ ] short of the dead or
something
oh my god yeah i mean you know like a
lot of things happened this weekend but
uh i think all in all it was a positive
experience i'd say this episode is
sponsored by expressvpn guys how much
time do you spend on your phone nowadays
all the time and what'd you guys do on
your phone just browse on the web the
scary part is that your phone carrier
collects all the data on whatever you're
doing verizon even admitted it
they say it's so that you can get a
better understanding of your interest
but really all they want to do is sell
your activities to advertisers the more
they can get on you the larger their
paycheck becomes which is why i use
expressvpn expressvpn is the app that
prevents your phone carrier from being
able to see the sites you visit and sell
it off to third parties all it takes is
one tap of a button and all of your
network data gets encrypted and rerouted
through expressvpn's secure servers for
ultimate privacy not only does it shield
your web browsing expressvpn protects
all of your network data so you can stay
private even when using your favorite
apps and the best part is one
subscription can be used for up to five
devices at the same time i have my whole
family using expressvpn i don't have a
family but if i did they would all be on
expressvpn take back your online privacy
today ladies and gentlemen by using
expressvpn.com trash taste that's
express ssvpn.com
taste links in the description below
back to the episode it was cool and
weird having bodyguards we got
bodyguards on the last age oh yeah yeah
yeah
what happened on uh saturday which is
the main panel and gone getting shot by
a nerf gun and stuff yeah yeah yeah they
kind of were like all right i uh we will
step this up a lot and then they went
like
props to them
like four [ __ ] bodyguards without so
i felt excessive but i i appreciate it
yeah uh had a really nice guy who would
just it was really chill and it would
speak to me and then it was really
strange going into the toilet and just
coming out of the toilet and he's just
like waiting for me and i'm like okay
this is weird but it makes sense it was
cool you know i he was he was very
professional i i see why you know people
don't mind having one because you know i
thought it was going to be really
overbearing having someone like behind
you yeah yeah but he was really nice he
just kind of like stood back and uh
whenever he felt anything was happening
he'd just kind of introduce himself or
not just kind of
yeah it was really good i mean it was
nice i mean definitely we uh learned
that we have to get it now for yeah
ax and like future conventions that
we're going to uh yeah i mean this like
like i said this is like our first
convention since
starting trash taste and now we know
this is like set the president's
precedence
president that wasn't that word's really
given you a little trouble it is it is
it is the president mr president set the
standard for us yeah
yeah yeah but i mean i still had a great
time actually um that was awesome like
yeah i said everyone was super nice like
getting to
see people after so long has been like
crazy yeah just reminding you that
great people exist yeah man you know
just like seeing everyone seeing like
the gifts that we've been given yeah as
well so many [ __ ] talented artists
and stuff as well yeah yeah yeah i think
my favorite gift that uh was given like
to all of us actually was there was this
like wooden there was this wooden trash
taste plaque and it was like perfectly
crafted i'm just like there was such
great craftsmanships on it i'm like oh
this is like this looks amazing and i
remember like garping at it with joey
and just like we were just like admiring
like the craftsmanship and then we're
like we turn it around and he says
someone gave me these cards and i found
them in my pocket earlier and one that
just says ham on lord of striking
thunder oh yeah this is the cards right
yeah i don't know i don't know there's
hamon and yugioh yeah there is yeah why
is the hammer in yugioh i don't know
this one is raviol lord of phantasms i
didn't really understand why that one
was relevant to me
i think harmon is my one actually what's
up
yeah the [ __ ] yeah i was given hamilton
dude someone just gave me a yugioh card
i don't know i mean i just i had it at
my pocket i think i think they gave one
for gone as well but
it must be in the bag of stuff yeah yeah
just so wow that's cool yeah so uh yeah
thank you to everyone who showed up and
like gave gifts and you know signing and
the panel and all that it was yeah it
was really really cool yeah really cool
are you guys would you guys think about
getting like masks to wear for like
future conventions and stuff like that
uh i bet it's a better disguise
no that was a solid disguise dude do you
want to talk about the disguise you were
thinking of okay okay okay you know what
you know what like after seeing what
happened on the second day i i call up
my mates and uh who was on like like the
the floor and like i was like can you
buy me a mask because i want to see if
like the mask works like a full like
facebook face mask right and so
um they buy me a mask i'm not gonna say
what it is in case i end up using it for
future conventions right they buy me a
mask of a character yeah that's that's
all i'm going to say yeah and so they we
go to the bar afterwards they bring me
the masks and we and i try it on in
front of joey and i'm like joey does
this mask work at all can you tell it's
me and the first thing joey says is like
you ain't you went tricky and are you
anyone
no because like it's like the mask like
just covers the face right why because
god's hair stands up it's just god's
hair above it like you can tell from
like if you are aware of what god's hair
looks like it's so freaking obvious i'm
like yep that's gone
yeah because like i i knew that wasn't
gonna work because uh you know back in
uh ax 2018 2019 whichever the last one
was yeah aki and i tried to do the same
thing right but like we had like
we didn't even have like a face mask we
had like a full like full covering the
head like balaclava style like masks
yeah yeah we're both wearing that we're
like yeah we're gonna get away with this
they'll never freaking know yeah and we
were walking from the hotel to the
convention which was like a two three
minute walk yeah and as soon as i got
out of the hotel someone was like hey
joey
i was just like [ __ ]
damn it
was just a perfect disguise i
immediately gave up yeah so i don't
think i don't think it's gonna work
that's why i was laughing my ass off
when conor was like they'll never know
it's me i didn't expect it to work yeah
i was like it'll just buy me enough time
you might as well just add a sign that
says i am conor that trash does just
like it says i am not confident i am not
gonna i'll do that
sure we'll get a giant [ __ ] like one
one of those pizza flipping something
yeah
arrow here that's like i am not coming
now because like i actually did try it
on sunday and it worked for a bit
actually
because like people would definitely
recognize me like hey like as i was
walking around the convention uh people
would definitely recognize me but it
wasn't like it was like the corner strap
well what kind of wanted to do which was
it brought you enough time
that they didn't like you didn't get
stopped immediately
but i could see like on like every like
fifth person i walked past they they did
like the double take they did like the
double right they would walk past and
then like something would click and then
they just like is that yeah yeah yeah or
like yeah who was that guy i i felt i
felt a disturbance in the force for a
second there but like that bought me
enough time to be like okay they've
looked around and i'm already like
like enough the world yeah yeah so it it
definitely didn't hide my identity but
it made people wouldn't like
not immediately not like immediately
like not run up from a distance yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and i i think like
as long as you don't stop in one place
for too long then then it's useful but
but the problem with that is that like
you know if you if you have that
particular mask on for instance then the
word is going to spread so yeah yeah
yeah yeah so the guy in that mask yeah
that's gone right and then it just
doesn't work anymore right because it's
like now they're just looking for the
guy in that mode
right it's a one trick pony yeah yeah
yeah exactly you got to get like a new
mask for like every day or like every
[ __ ] convention or something
yeah because because i did see like a
couple of like people i knew like
youtubes and stuff who were like going
it like like cosplay yeah and stuff like
that and i'm like okay like that's smart
because you're like you're in a full
cosplay time exactly so it's not just
like covering the head type of thing so
like but like in saying that am i
bothered to get like a full on like full
body cosplay to like walk around no i'm
so hot yeah it is
speaking of cosplay though my god
gention has like taken over this year
yeah oh my god like every third
cosplayer i saw was against yeah like
because because normally like i remember
like the anime con experiences like one
or two characters would completely take
over now it was just like the entire
cast of genshin you know there was a lot
of genji i didn't realize yeah it was
that popular yeah because i remember in
like 2018 2019 i think the the big thing
at least for people who came up to my
signing was like nekopara characters and
i think i saw like two nickel power
characters today and i was like oh okay
make a power is that big yeah i mean
there was a lot i mean because you know
it's so easy to cosplay right yeah and
there's so many variations so like it's
it's very easy for a lot of people to
cosplay it but yeah like
now it's just like genshin or demon
slayer or i saw a lot of demons
yeah but like i i like my mates are
telling me that like the gentian line or
the line to buy genji merch was like by
far like the longest line i don't even
know they're not selling yeah yeah yeah
exactly and i'm just like well this is
the closest any [ __ ] genji fan is
going to get to buying actual feel real
merch
but there was one part of me that was
like oh man there's like so many like
genji characters you know being
cosplaying and it's like oh yeah this is
like a new era of like cosplaying in at
cons but yeah the one thing where i was
like oh yeah this will never change is
people coming up to me making me sign
death notes
like oh my god i was like that that is a
piece of con culture that will probably
never go away that will never that will
never go away and i'm like all right
that's familiar right there yeah
[ __ ] i just remembered that happened to
me as well i probably signed like 10 or
20 death notes like during this week and
i was like all right that's that's one
piece of like con culture i'm glad we'll
never go away it's like it's going to
the point where like i i know the
notebook now when i get when i get given
it right because because they they make
it like you always get like the death
note and then they make you sign it and
then they're like close the cover and
they're like they're like staring at you
you know they're like ha what do you
think and i'm just like haha you got me
yeah the pages are very noticeable yeah
exactly
it's like i don't know like i don't even
have to like flip the cover anymore to
see what i'm saying i'm just like yeah
that's definitely are you superstitious
about it i know some people don't sign
death notes because they're like oh what
if i actually what who i've met some
people who don't sign them really yeah
oh ah because are you wishing me to die
or something that's [ __ ] up
no i don't care
i mean like i s also another thing is
like there's a lot of people that try to
get get you in like these nut strokes
nowadays as well yes that's the new like
death note like trick now yeah yeah it's
like i i had a couple of people being
like oh can you sign this for my friend
he couldn't be here because he had ligma
and i was just you know and i'm like
this close to being like oh i'm sorry
for your friend
and i have to stop myself
yeah i think i think this guy tried it
on all three of us yeah i think i was
first and i just was like all right nice
it's like ligma okay wow
i was like come on man do you really
think that's gonna [ __ ] work come on
i must say that the dude who found that
restaurant in london which was called
secondus yeah yeah yeah yeah that was i
think that was i was like i was like all
right you deserve yeah that's like
that's like a dee's nuts joke that hack
had like had effort put into it yeah
like i respect that yeah cause he he got
us like uh these like indian or i think
like uh like indian nuts or something
yeah yeah it was like it was like a
snack that was made out of nuts it was
like oh i got you some nuts from second
i was like okay that's kind of funny
that was really it's like i'll take it
i'm like you know what i respect the
creativity i'll take that yeah
what was something like what was some
other gifts that you guys got
uh was anything that stood out oh there
was one actually uh we got it yesterday
but there was uh this guy this artist
guy who gave us this like poster and
he's like a mecca artist right and he
made this like maybe it's on the screen
maybe it's on screen i don't know but
like he made this uh like trash taste
mecca essentially oh my god yeah and
it's like full on like yeah
it was like kind of a cross between a
gundam and an ava type of thing but it
was like it had like the trash taste
purple on it and it looked really
freaking cool and it was like yeah i did
it in two days and i was like
what the hell
i wish i could do that
it was really nice i really wanted to
give it to alan because i know he's like
a massive make-a-head yeah yeah so i've
like held on to it so i'll give it to
i'll give it to alan that's really cool
but um yeah like yeah there was just
like so many cool like just i don't know
really like talented people like a girl
gave me like a ring that she had like
made as well
yeah and uh yeah i don't know it's like
it's it's you know obviously like you
know pieces of fan on stuff like that is
like amazing as well and like we've kept
all of it obviously but um yeah i got
like a custom pokemon card for mine in
sydney's wedding it was like oh really
just like proper metal and everything i
was like that was pretty [ __ ] cool
that was one of the coolest gifts i've
ever had
i remember there was a guy who came to
my signing on the friday and he made me
sign uh like a hollow yu-gi-oh card and
i was like oh that's really cool i
haven't seen that in a long time yeah he
came back on the sunday to give me the
card oh like like
in film like this oh [ __ ] and i was just
like it's like yeah i like scoured all
over the contour like finder for you
yeah and it like came back on the sunday
it's like give it to me and i was just
like you the g bro
you're the g
give me a limited edition first
charizard please
like one did you
did you get someone did you get a
masterpiece
uh no she's like yeah the guy
i was really disappointed he brought out
a copy of masterpiece right uh which is
like the hang tiger yeah
um like it was like the full dojin
colored
yeah and uh i was like oh my god and i
was like he said yeah he's shining for
me and i'm like can i have it and he was
like no
and i was like i was like hey i gotta
shoot my shot yeah it's like oh this you
got this for me yeah it was like a giant
[ __ ] i was like
this poor guy behind so we had like
obviously you have like a handler at a
con basically the handler's job is to
just kind of get you to where you need
to go and also help with the signings
kind of help with the flow yeah and uh
he was like this normal british dude who
just like he was talking about football
and stuff and i pretended like i
understood what was going on
and um
i i take out this masterpiece to sign it
and i just open it up and i'm like nice
i said he's like whoa
whoa
i'm like oh yeah this is not normal
this is not a normal thing to open and
just admire right now
and so i closed it and i was oh he was
like wow that was that was intense and i
was like oh yeah yeah
right we hit him
no i i totally just like bought into it
because like my handler who was next to
me she was just like oh yeah you've like
signed some pretty weird things and i'm
like you haven't seen anything yet and
then literally as i said that some dude
was like uh can i get you to sign
something that's like very questionable
and i was like all right here we go and
he pulls out like a sasuke x naruto like
yowie dose i signed that as well and he
was like and he was like and i was like
where do you want me to sign like on the
cover and stuff like that and he's like
no open it up and find the most [ __ ]
up page to sign it on and i was like i
don't want to open this in front of my
handler being like oh wonder where's the
most [ __ ] up scene
and then i i did find the most [ __ ] up
scene and i was like alright there and
she was just like i'm not no judging you
know what yeah if this is these are your
fans i guess you know and i was like
yeah
[Laughter]
but like i had a similar experience uh
because okay we've talked a lot about
mcm i would say like the signing
experience was like the smoothest
signing experience i've ever had yeah
definitely at any convention like they
had this [ __ ] on lockdown like it was
like in and out in and out you know take
your stuff they gave us like a post note
of like what they wanted us to sign what
the what the person's name was it was
like excellent it was so streamlined
yeah it was so streamlined uh i remember
the first one the first sus one that i
got was uh it was a manga called like i
think like dick fight island or
something yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah i think i remember that yeah
it was dick fight island and i was just
like oh what's this and he goes he was
like oh sydney recommended it and i was
just like that sounds like sydney nation
and he just goes off on like he just
starts going off on like the entire
synopsis right of dick fight island
which is apparently just a bunch of
dudes on an island and they fight with
their dicks that's what i'm guessing is
but he goes into it in like such graphic
detail right and so i'm like yeah that
sounds like a really really interesting
story i signed it he goes away we had
like a little five minute breather and
my handler goes to me
so what do you do
it's a long story
like i'm like how do i how do i explain
this you know you should have just been
like yes i'm the author of dick fight
island
oh you know what actually i got someone
came out to me who is like uh this is a
reference i guess to anyone who has
watched this episode of trash taste he
was like oh
man i love your work and then he just
gives me a copy of goblin slow
and i was like yeah yeah yeah and he was
like oh can you sign it and i was like
yeah dude let's do it
sign the goblin slayer oh my god oh yeah
oh god that was interesting yeah i mean
there's a lot of
normal things everyone's like bro
everyone thinks that like they're gonna
hand you the weirdest thing yeah they're
like oh oh i'm gonna show you something
really out there yeah and it's it's like
all right
i've shined like everything and i love
how it's those people who are always
like oh i'm sorry you're probably you've
never signed anything this weird and i'm
just like
i have no idea
this is baby mode right it's baby
yeah so did anything else notable happen
to you at the convention
oh i don't know
did anything i mean i i got to see a lot
of people i haven't seen in years which
was did you did you guys get recognized
anywhere like at a weird place that like
was not in the convention oh i i got oh
because uh the hotel they put us in was
like literally like the con hotel yeah
so like anyone who's going to the con
was staying in this hotel yeah
and like i'm in the elevator sorry lyft
um
and
uh wow you've changed
i've changed so i come on the lift right
and uh there's this guy and he's like oh
wow you're sea dog right and i'm like
yeah yeah what's up he's like yo can i
have a picture i'm like yeah sure let's
do it let's do it yeah
so like i'm taking a picture with this
guy and he's like he's trying to get his
phone ready and he's like giving stuff
to his girlfriend or whoever this is
yeah and this girlfriend's like
who is this guy yeah and he was like yo
it's it's sea dog and she's like all
right and he's like yeah you should i
used to watch his videos
bruh that's a that's a bra that's a
problem
and i like he said this to her and
looked at me and just smiled like ready
for the picture and i'm like
i was like i was like what the [ __ ] dude
like
like are you just like what happened
yeah i get it maybe you get busy right
but you could say that like later wait
why are you gonna say it to my face
that's kind of like let's kind of scare
like l plus ratio fell off like
yeah this guy was like i used to watch
his videos and i mean he like just
smiled at me and i was like i was like
brother
used to
well i mean i guess like one notable
thing was uh the panel that we had on
sunday
how did that go because i wasn't there
yeah so it was kind of like so the
saturday panel was kind of like a q a
type of thing right yeah i was like
there was a microphone in the crowd
people could come up and ask the
questions
type of thing uh but the sunday one it
was like the title of it was a
conversation with the anime mansion va
so we structured it kind of like it was
me and connor on the stage and then we
kind of had like an mc type of thing who
was there to navigate and ask like
general questions like get a flow of
conversation going right and uh because
we asked this mc guy who was a great amc
mind you but it was very last minute
right yeah he obviously didn't know who
me and connor were what we do right like
he only knew like a very baseline
information yeah so uh you know
obviously the a lot of the questions
were like very general
but
then that was one question
it was like uh
something along the lines of like yeah
so uh i i was uh an emceeing for uh
your wife sid snap
and he was like and he was like and he
was like looking straight at me
and i was like
uh and i looked at conor and uh you know
we kind of like met eyes and i looked
back at the mc i was like
could you repeat it
was like yeah yeah you're your fiance
and wife uh a sydney or sid snap yeah
she uh she was telling me all these
stories about how you know the you know
planning for the wedding and all that
kind of stuff and i was like
and you know there was a murmur
happening in the crowd and i was like um
and i just like slowly pulled my hand
out and i was like i'm joey by the way
[ __ ] it's like no no you're you're
you're grant or god right
and i was like is this really happening
is accidental racism happening live on
stage right now
and uh and i think people in the crowd
were kind of like ah yeah funny bit yeah
yeah yeah good nice nice nice execution
nice landing guys like meanwhile i'm
just like
this [ __ ] literally confused me
with a gun like what all asians look the
same now is that how it is
congratulations on getting married to
sydney by the way thank you thank you
hope the winning goes well
you know i've been planning it for a
while now you know how it is
oh and i think uh alan said at best uh
last night he was like wow i can't
believe he confused the anime zone with
the anime man
easy mistake you know he's a mistake
when you put it that way fair enough i
don't know none of you are watching
anime right yeah yeah
[Laughter]
i
you know he kind of got dragged to do it
last minute and i could tell when like
and he was like trying to double down on
him that was the thing that i was like
no no come on baby he was like no i'm
sure it was something something i no
just just move on and then and then
there was a moment during the panel
where like people in the crowd started
to laugh when he doubled down and just
like wouldn't land and he just like put
both his hands in his face and he was
just like oh no i've made a horrible
mistake and i was like don't worry man
it's fine it was funny it was funny and
harmless and you know great great story
for the podcast i was like it's whatever
yeah but other than that yeah why are
you gone
you are god
i am not god you are god
one funny thing that happened actually
was uh
so you know i got recognized by someone
i got you know took a picture with them
and they were like you're not gonna
believe this i saw the most convincing
sydney lookalike i've ever seen in my
life okay i'm like oh okay let's let let
me see this what's like i i want to see
if there's a my wife look alike yeah
yeah
you like exactly like gets out his phone
like puts puts the picture on starts
swiping like furiously and he goes look
at that
does that not look like sydney and it's
him that's standing next to sydney
and i'm pretty damn good-looking
and i'm just like
my god i think that's just sydney and
he's like no no let me show you another
picture she he shows me a full body shot
of sydney
and i'm like
no
i think i think you are just got a
picture of sydney i want to know
what sydney looks like in this guy's
hand like the real sydney what he looks
like in this guy's hand how did so how
did he take a picture of sydney and like
explain it to her no because because
what he explained to me was no you you
don't understand like i asked her if she
was sid snap and she said no what like
why
because sydney being the troll that she
is sometimes she's like are you sinish
like now
yeah so this guy's like can we take a
picture just so you know i i just gotta
i just get i just got it you look so
much like sydney i just need to take a
picture so sydney takes leave
inspired
it's like well i guess she's not there
she's like so what he was saying was
like he's told me yeah she looked like
sydney yeah and she sounded like sydney
but she told me she wasn't sydney so
there's a so this this british dude
thought there was an american sydney
look alike
in london i think he thought she must
have been cosplaying sydney
like that's a wig right that's what
you're really
saying it's your girl probably should be
like committed to this like heart
i remember because like i was with a
friend and i was like because we were
outside a hotel and i was just like
because he like refused to believe me
that he was like sydney so i'm like can
you like i turned to my friend like can
you go get sydney please and he's just
like he was just like so like shell
shock like it was like speech a hundred
no sydney was just like cindy had like
convinced him that she just was not
sydney by saying one line that i am not
sid snap and then like so my friend gets
sydney and the first thing he she says
is you stupid [ __ ]
japanese debated
i love how all it took for sydney to get
away from that situation was her just
saying no meanwhile this guy's in a full
[ __ ] like
disguise and he can't get away with it
at all maybe i should just you know
just be like are you see he'd always
like nah nah i'm not like oh well [ __ ] i
guess it's not yeah yeah oh i love your
videos who yeah
who was you
did it again what the [ __ ] well i mean
to be fair you you weren't sea dog that
weekend you were sea dogs
one of my favorite pictures of that
entire weekend was just
your your like face of just confusion in
front of your picture it wasn't even
like me pulling i was just walking yeah
he was literally just walking and i just
like took a candid shot i've kind of
just been like
in front of the side that said see dogs
v8 because it just looked like
your face just looked like you just you
have just like gone through like like
you're not you're like the end of the
universe you want to explain what's
happening because i explained about this
okay so at the signing right we had like
a dedicated section for our signing you
know there was a picture of all three of
us that said trash taste and then there
was individual photos of like yeah man
gig and then next to that there was a
picture of connor
but it's instead of saying c dog va it
said see dogs with a z yeah va
and i i remember i like you know i was
admiring you know the posters being like
oh yeah you know we look sick in these
and then i did a double take with
connor's like
see what he said
i don't know i see dogs
me neither and i was just like i was
just like you should change your name to
see dogs va it looks so sick
it was that and they were coming the
next day and it's just like like black
that would make and i laughed even
it was the most like inconspicuous like
i just kind of felt like i was like i
don't care everything everyone kept
coming out to me like wow you must be so
offended i'm like why would i give a
[ __ ] yeah i mean i've had that happen
before yeah yeah yeah i've had it
yeah i was just like i don't really care
it's not like it's i'm suddenly now like
a different person it's like a file
location where if you type in the wrong
thing it's like dot c-dog dot exe is
missing it's like
i'm still here like at least like at
least you know the large majority of
your name was still there and intact
like i've had i've been to a convention
where they had a sign up and it said the
anime guy yeah so i'm just like i'm like
that's just a completely different
person
they must've done that on purpose to
[ __ ] with it no no they weren't they
were genuine they genuinely thought i
was the anime guy and i was and i didn't
have the heart to tell them yeah at the
time another timeline i was just like
all right you know what i'm it's good
enough [ __ ] it yeah for me like every
convention i go to it's like a 50 chance
of whether it be giggup or gig uk that
is that is like i swear half the
conventions i go to is just gig uk
unfortunately i guess i guess it's
helpful for having kids
in london it should have been gig uk
yeah it makes sense right yeah it's uh
when we go to like australia it'll be
gig aus right yeah yeah yeah yeah
or just geek us in like us
in america
but yeah like another thing like i
noticed is just like
every time you like you hang out with
your mates or with somewhere where you
think you're private it's just like if
if someone mentions that wouldn't this
be a funny time for you to get noticed
it is like the worst [ __ ] it is it is
all it's like summoning the devil you
know it is going to happen so that
because that happened to me uh well it
happened to me indirectly right because
so we were outside a hotel and we were
just
you know chilling out there was pretty
late at night it was about 1am uh and we
see this guy just stumble over to like
the tree
and he just starts throwing up right and
he and we're just like [ __ ] who is is he
all right he's uh he's obviously not in
the right state of mind i don't know
where his mates are um so we go over to
him and he's obviously had too many
drinks uh that night yeah uh and
unfortunately he didn't know where his
mates were which if you're watching this
guy if you're watching this and you uh
happen to be a trash taste watcher get
better mates
you don't leave your mates down you
don't leave your mates out like that
exactly
oh that's quite [ __ ] up yeah yeah yeah
yeah so it's by the tree uh luckily you
know luckily some some some guys uh some
like a father had uh had found him and
was trying to make sure that he was okay
and so we went over and started to help
out as well just to make sure that he
was kosher and everything uh making sure
that uh
he was all right he was all right he's
going to get home uh so we managed to
contact his sister
and keep in mind it's like one
1am 2am you know like he's just out here
in the middle of london and she was like
i believe like on the other side of
london or something and we were just
like
can you come pick your brother up and uh
you know being being the giga chad
sister that she was she's like yeah yeah
just tell me where she is let me get
there now i'll i'll come bring him home
right so we were with him for like a
good like you know half hour to 45
minutes making sure he was okay making
sure he was warm you know make sure he
wasn't too passed out um and just
being hopefully being a good samaritan
while waiting for this
waiting for this mythical sister to come
being a good replacement for the [ __ ]
mates yeah yeah yeah yeah that's right
right
um and so we're with him for half an
hour of 245 minutes and then i go i go
into the toilet
uh quickly and then as i come outside
apparently when i was in the toilet this
mythical sister comes right and she's
just like oh thank you so much for
taking care of my brother i'm so sorry
you know i don't know what's happened to
his mates i don't know what's happened
to him um i'll make sure he gets home
okay and then like the next line which
is the line i heard as i was walking out
uh to uh as i was walking out the door
to go outside again was by the way did
you guys see the trash chase boys in the
mcm today
yeah yeah yeah the sisters said this
right it was like my mates told me it
was like sitcom level timing right she
was like so compassionate and then she
was just trying to make conversation
yeah and then she she she just mentioned
have you did you guys manage to see the
trash table
slowly back inside no no and then like
the automatic doors open and then
everyone looks at me and she just goes
no
no
you wait you're on the phone with her
all right no i was i wasn't on the phone
but i i mean i uh i wasn't on the phone
with her it was uh someone else on the
phone but right they had mentioned that
you know we had a bunch of guys taking
care um of of her brother and i i was
like the guy who was just like chatting
to him trying to get trying to make sure
trying to know what the [ __ ] happened to
him tonight sure he felt comfortable
with that [ __ ] and he's just like
you were taking care of him you you
yeah
and i'm just like are you the sister are
you the mythical sister yeah i'm just
like yes
and i was like i was like first i said
yo thank you so much for being [ __ ]
amazing and she's like
i could tell like she was like trying to
hold in her excitement and then and then
she like she pauses for a second she
looks at her brother dead on the floor
and she's like
i know this is a bad time
but is it cool if i ask for a picture
no
no no and i'm just like doesn't even
sound real dude
i 100 it happened and i'm just like look
you were like such a [ __ ] giga chart
for coming all the way out here like 1am
uh
luckily we had other people to take care
of her brother which is like we take a
quick picture she goes home and uh
everyone's safe everyone's please tell
me the brother was in the shot like in
the
like it's like that mean picture of the
guy like leaning towards the grave and
like doing that
except it's like the brotherhood is just
like dead on the ball like
it doesn't even sound real like it
sounds so like like in between his eyes
it was like so surreal
one of the funniest things that happened
to me that weekend um but yes it's just
like sometimes you just have like really
weird coincidences and weird timings
with [ __ ] man
that is like the words you must never
utter at a con yeah of like huh what if
hilarious right and then almost every
single time it's like
from a distance you know right right
[ __ ] sake
where's the candle yeah yeah yeah yeah
where's where where's the live audience
yeah yeah
oh my god we are like aside from mcm
though i mean how is your guys
experience being back in the uk now i
mean this is your second time in the uk
i don't know if it's only my second time
here yeah i don't know if you had a lot
of chance to explore england outside
we've been in
like because the mcm in london is kind
of out of the way so we've kind of been
just kind of contained there right and
like the first time i was around i think
in like
2017 2018 whenever it was like i was
mostly in brighton at god's place right
so i think i was only in london for
maybe like
a day yeah yeah or so so this is i think
this will be like my first proper time
kind of like getting to check it out and
i've already seen way more of london
than i ever did last time so yeah it's
been it's been nice it's been sure i
mean the weather's been [ __ ]
fantastic this weekend as well which is
great because like everyone was like oh
you're here when i tweeted about like oh
yeah you know i'm landing in london soon
haha it's gonna be sick yeah everyone
was just like weather's going to be [ __ ]
[ __ ] weather
expect the [ __ ] weather it's been really
good yeah and i landed i was just like
bro
this is is this a [ __ ] weather
literally i remember the first day
meeting you i was like you couldn't ask
for like better weather it was literally
clear scarf yeah it's clear blue it was
like warm like not too hot like nice and
toasty yeah right you know perfect
sunglasses like having a coffee outside
type of weather yeah yeah and everyone
was like shoot weather shoot with them i
was like
apparently though it was just like an
absolute fluke like yeah everyone was
like damn it's a [ __ ] it's actually good
weather here yeah yeah yeah i think
around this time of year it's okay
though yeah yeah this is a pretty good
time to come because the last time i was
in the uk it was like the biggest heat
wave in like 30 years it's like
everywhere everything
it's the biggest heat wave every [ __ ]
year yeah yeah we get one week or in
your case it was like the one month yeah
of just that was really [ __ ] hot yeah
like holy [ __ ] like the heat wave in the
uk just we are not built for it and i
was just like where's the ac
where's the ac we don't have it yeah
yeah no i mean yeah it's been good so
far i haven't done anything oh god dude
i had that really awkward uh
interaction at the hotel that was really
like
levels of uh awkwardness
well so we're
in the hotel bar just talking to all our
friends
you know because it's the sunday it's
after the contender everyone's just
chilling we're all just hanging out
saying bye to all our friends and uh
this person was like pretty chill at
first and like they would come up and be
like oh hi you know do you want to drink
or anything i was like no no it's okay
it's okay yeah and i got my got my
friend to buy me a drink instead uh and
take that money
um yeah and then they kind of like just
kept kind of you know kept saying hi
which is fine like it's chill because
people do it all the time and it's like
whatever probably a couple of drinks
deep right yeah yeah yeah like
if someone's having a drink
a bunch of drinks enjoying themselves
they want to be like oh my god yeah yeah
it's like whatever i don't mind that
yeah um but i noticed that like whenever
we would like if i went outside or like
any of you guys went outside they would
like kind of like also then happen to go
outside
at the same time
and just listen to whatever you're
talking about and then you know i'd go
to the toilet then suddenly okay they
were in the toilet as well and i was
like okay this is like all right a
little suspect like nothing happened so
i was like all right cool cool cool
that's chill it's kind of like
tailgating a little bit yeah just kind
of like watching i guess which is like
obviously it's like not ideal but it's
nothing bad like i'm not like whatever
uh but then like you guys went to bed
and there was only like maybe like six
of us left we were chilling yeah and uh
there was like there was like two
couches and there's like an empty space
because obviously you know you guys can
bed and stuff
and they came over and they were like
hey uh do you mind if i like take that
seat it was like 1am so it's kind of
winding down yeah and i was like yeah i
mean i don't really think that's like
appropriate because like no one really
knows you you only know me you know it's
kind of it's kind of weird and stuff and
they were like oh
oh okay
well do you mind if i just introduced
myself to everyone then and i was like i
was like
sorry i was like yeah no i don't i don't
think that's like the best i think you
know it's you know i i appreciate it but
like no i i it makes this a bit more
like the intention is there but clearly
i didn't quite read them yeah i was i
was trying to be like as like polite but
like
no as possible right because like you
know at the end of the day like there's
still somebody who
even though i guess some people would be
like no you have the permission to be
like [ __ ] off at that point yeah yeah
people just people say that i'm like i
still don't want to do that like to me
it's like they're still a person i don't
want to be that guy they shoot at their
shot and it didn't work and they should
have just given up at that point but
then after after i said that again i was
like no i don't think that's come on man
like no i just kind of like stood there
awkwardly just like looking at us
and then it was just kind of like
all my friends are just looking at me
like
and i was like yeah like yeah please do
something i'm like okay all right man
bye yeah
wouldn't leave and then
one of our friends just goes
what the [ __ ] did he say
he was like just please leave us alone
like he's begging like in like a
pleading way was like please just leave
us alone please please
i think i know who i think yeah yeah
yeah
it was in such a like desperate way that
the person was like yeah oh yeah sorry
sorry sorry yeah
it's like just like like oh no but that
was really funny the way he said that
that was really please
please leave us alone
yeah i mean i mean
you know when you when you hang out at
the bar at the convention in the
convention hotel this shit's gonna
happen like if we really wanted to go
somewhere else and like avoid this [ __ ]
we could have right but like we just
wanted the convenience we were all
staying in that hotel
yeah yeah so like i when people do [ __ ]
like that i know people get like really
like that's [ __ ] up that they did that
i'm like yeah it's not ideal but i'm
also like you know people get excited
they shoot their shot they didn't do
anything they they asked yeah they
didn't just sit down because people have
done that before yeah people just
[ __ ] pulled up yeah like on the panel
yeah yeah yeah like i'm glad it's like
i'm glad people can now know that we
aren't bullshitting no yeah
you can
you have the right anyone has the right
to be like hey can i join you and i have
the right to say no yeah and [ __ ] off
like exactly
i'm not gonna get pissed at someone for
trying to shoot their shot yeah if you
want to whatever yeah is it is it kind
of rude and insensitive to do it yeah it
is but at the same time but at the same
time like respect my privacy yeah yeah
if you did it respectfully i'm gonna
give you the respect to be like explain
it nicely like that's not appropriate no
and if you don't get it
then maybe one of my friends won't be so
nice but i'll still be nice but
i don't know please just leave the phone
you know i i i we i don't know i just
say these stories because it's like it's
on my mind i wanted to talk about it but
i i know it's gonna happen again it's
gonna be the last time uh yeah if you
ever see me around and you ask to sit
next to me i'm probably gonna say no 99
no no [ __ ] i'm going to say no uh
i'm i'm gonna say i'm gonna say no
probably because i don't know you and
it's weird you know and uh yeah it's
like it's not organic yeah yeah i think
in a convention setting it's hard to
like draw
like a comfortable line you know whereas
maybe if you meet someone at a bar and
you're not with like a massive group of
friends it's different it's different
it's difficult definitely it's very it's
very different it's like it's you kind
of do have to like read the room
sometimes which i know some people
aren't as in tune with that as other
people but you know you try not to hold
things against people unless they like
seriously do cross like a social
boundary yeah you know
um
in which case maybe i should listen to
[ __ ] die this morning just be like
sorry man yeah man
did you use the man did you use the man
i don't know i think i just waffled
for 10 minutes just being like no no
here's another here's another reason why
no here's another reason why no if you
would have just said sorry man then that
would be like all right man i respect
that
that's what we should have said to that
guy who came on stage [ __ ]
he was right all along just turned and
being like sorry man
sorry man let's just say the place now
man
there was this one dude that i i like
she doesn't like know what his deal was
i was like we were at the bar with john
and john was talking to me and i was
like man yeah it sucks dude like you
know i was like yeah it kind of started
right
i'm sorry
i i did it
but we've said john like a million times
right
so many other jobs
literally such a common name i was in my
own head i'm sorry yeah okay that's my
bad i suck dude
oh yeah i was telling super eye patch
fool if i was like yeah man sucks dude
like you know i don't feel like i can't
really like experience a con the way i
used to and then
while i'm telling this story to john
this guy who must have been like 40 or
50 just shouts full on from across the
bar he's like hey connor
connor you want a drink you want a drink
and i'm like nah i'm good man
and john was like you know that guy i'm
like not a [ __ ] clown
that was it that was it that was like
because like they they shout your name
in such familiarity that even i'm even i
have to double take to be like do i know
this yeah did you know what i mean
like a few times when i hang out with
mates like over here like go on hey gone
gone and i'm just like oh it's uh i
wait i i i don't i've never met this man
in my life
it's my friend of a friend no
yeah
don't you don't offer me a drink i'm
privileged as you all say so don't [ __ ]
i had one time i was in london last time
i never told this there's like someone
um like a mexican restaurant
it was like the thing in the movie it
was like the person over there wants to
buy you a drink
this is [ __ ] cool yeah yeah i'll have
it
and you bought me like the strongest
drink on the [ __ ] menu and i was like
it's like trying to spike so yeah so
then i realized i was like yeah i'm not
doing this again
i'm not letting them choose the drink
though the weirder one for me is like
the ones where it's like just in passing
but you're also like not too sure either
because of the lack of information like
it's the ones where you're like when
you're in the hotel lobby and you're
trying to get to the toilet or something
and then a person is walking past you
and you just very briefly
have eye contact and they just go
like
and then they walk off and i'm just like
do i know
and it's not until i turn around and
sometimes they'll turn around be like
you know like hey love your stuff and i
was like hope you're having a good night
and stuff like that you know maybe
they're just being friendly i don't know
but it's like it's just the silent knot
like what is this code for something
like
yeah
but uh that's cool though sorry it's
cool like that's the one thing i i guess
as well that i've just been like kind of
getting back used to again because yeah
you know because i personally have been
stuck in japan for the past three years
now and it's like yeah stranger
friendliness is not as big of a thing as
it is saying like the uk yeah especially
in a con setting so it's like i'm just
getting used to just random people just
being like hey yeah we've gone through
like
i feel like it has been like just us
readjusting and reacclimating to con
culture because it's been like such a
we've gone from like zero to like two
hundred percent you know and like in
like the span in like the span of a day
and it's just like i've forgotten one
how intense it was before like before
covert and everything and now it's like
even more intense because one covers
happen everyone's even more excited and
enthusiastic um and also we are way more
recognizable so it's just kind of like
all culminated into this massive
stirring pot i i know like for me it was
i know like i caught myself being like
oh man it's been such a long time since
i've been to a con because there's so
many times during the signing where like
you know because you're meeting so many
people right you start to get into like
a pattern of things to say yeah right
it's like it's like you start off with
the hello like how's your con experience
been how's your day been whatever and
then there was so many times where like
people would be like i hope you enjoy
your time in the uk and i'll be like
yeah you too
as if they're not from here
well there was a lot of people actually
who are like not from the uk yeah but
it's like it's like clearly i i every
time i said you two to that question it
was always the most like british
sounding person ever
like yeah as if they don't [ __ ] leave
you it's like damn it i think i said
that a few times not to that but like oh
thanks a lot for your content i go you
too
[Laughter]
so how did you know
i had a okay it's not not a con
experience uh we got a we had a cab back
uh me joey and a few other friends and
it was like it was like a 41 pounds this
is this cab ride so it was like 30
minutes it was a long time yeah yeah and
uh you know i went to go pay i gave the
guy because i only had like 10 so i gave
the guy 50 right
and i so i'm my head right i'm like okay
it's been like three years or like since
i've been like tipping
normally and i know that sometimes you
tip cab drivers in london and stuff and
i said okay yeah yeah i forgot about
this because i never took cabs and left
two before yeah yeah it was late and we
were in like the middle of nowhere so
i i pay this guy and then he's like oh
yeah
i'll i'll give you the change just get
out the car and i'll give you the change
so i you know you know get out the car
i'm kind of just tired it's like 3am
like i just want to go to bed yeah and
so the guy
uh i was like alright so can i have my
change because i the way i i tip i don't
know if you do this like i want all my
change first and then i will then i will
be like
here's your tip right yeah yeah and so
i was like oh can i have my change and
he was like what
it like he looked at me like he like he
i asked for change and then he just
looked at me like he wanted me to take
it back like he wanted me to pretend
like i should say yeah like like i was
like i was like bro what the [ __ ] like i
i was gonna tip him and then he's now
he's being weird about it and now i want
to tip him less because i'm like i'm
like just give me my [ __ ] i'm like
nine pounds is a lot right
this is not america we don't tip 20 yeah
right like
i i was going to give him like a fiver
that was my plan and then i was like
you're being weird about this man just
give me my [ __ ] money back yeah and
i'll give you some back like i was like
what the [ __ ] dude and so that's not
cool and so i i like i'm like all right
yeah i was like can i change and then he
like looks at me again for i want to say
it was the most awkward five to ten
seconds of my life that's right felt
like zawarido and jojo yeah i could feel
the one second
two seconds and i feel i feel like he
was trying to figure out if i was drunk
like right i was fine but i felt i felt
like he was trying to see if he was like
can i get away with this
and so he goes into his car he like
rummages around and he comes out and he
just gives me five pounds and i'm like
i'm like dude like
all right okay fine
fine he's probably thinking like maybe
if i just give him some money
i was going to give you the five pound
notes now you got four pound because
you're being a dick yeah and i'm like
why just just give me my money back and
i'll tip you i was like what the [ __ ]
and i was just like what a weird
experience yeah meanwhile the people in
the camp were just like vibing they're
like no i'm like having like this mind
battle with this cab driver they'd like
just tip him i should give him money and
he was making it weird i was like this
why are people like this yeah everyone
was like everyone else was in the car
just like kind of chatting and i'm just
like yeah just like dead on the [ __ ]
back seat not knowing that
i was just like bro okay and so he got
his four pound tip joke's on you you got
a five pound tip you're just giving me
all my change dude
yeah
this is a weird experience you don't get
in japan you don't you didn't no you
don't
like they just give you it back
immediately and you never have to deal
with this and it was just so weird just
seeing the guy just not want to give me
my [ __ ] change and i was just like
it's like me no speaking
it's just like yeah talking about like
transport in london i guess like i i
guess like there has been like a talk of
the town since uh since we got here
uh because everyone like that i've hung
out with can't stop talking about this
[ __ ] elizabeth line that's just
[ __ ] opened up yeah i like heard
about it and it's like some like fancy
new line that's like recently opened up
yeah yeah so apparently it's this it's
this line that's been planned for like
that was meant to open i believe in like
oh many years ago yeah yeah like like
2020 i believe nothing that's open
nothing in the uk yeah never gets done
on time yeah
and then it got it got delayed it got
delayed but like the hype was real
i thought like i come into london coming
to a convention people be like oh have
you started watching spike's family are
you watching any new anime no everyone's
like yo you've been on the elizabeth
line have you been on the elizabeth line
like i haven't i i haven't yet i haven't
and i i swear to god someone could just
like have given birth the day before i'd
be like baby nah bruh elizabeth line
that's the real hype man i gotta try my
i gotta try real stuff yeah yeah but
like from what i heard it's just like
it's a air-conditioned line and i'm just
like isn't that just every train in
japan
it's like the the series of questions we
got were very different to how the the
the list of questions i would normally
get at a signing right because like
before trash days it was always like
what do you think about this anime what
do you think about this manga and there
was like definitely like you know some
amounts of those yeah but i think the
top three questions i received
during that entire weekend was yeah
number one was have you had a tesco meal
deal yet number two was have you been to
greggs yet yes and number three was have
you been to spoons yet
like
nothing to do with anime it was all just
like have you had these things yeah have
you had any of them well yeah you took
me to a spoon the last time i was here
but apparently you took me to like the
worst it was the
yeah but no i i still haven't had the
tesco meal doing i really wanted greg's
i haven't had a grapes yet at all so uh
i mean yeah we're here for a little bit
i've forgotten how passionate people are
about greg's yeah that's very good
greg's is the bakery yes the bakery yeah
yeah so much more than that though yeah
it is it's it's an experience
you know i'm just a bakery yeah yeah
like i feel like you have to go there at
least once to get your british passport
you know that's that's the last test
like
because it's it's really weird because i
didn't realize how
unknown greg's was to people outside of
england right uh because you know we a
lot of people british people we speak
about nando's we speak about spoons but
like not a lot of people speak about
greg's abroad and it's just one of these
british things that if you're in england
you you would have been to a greg's at
least once in your life you might not
always talk about it but it's part of
being british right right and i didn't
realize this until i came back to
england and uh and you know everyone
started asking me if i'd gone to like if
i'd gone back to greg's yet
it's important greg's important thing i
feel yeah from from what i heard from
people like i feel
being british person and not going to
greg's is like being a japanese person
and not going to family mod
it's like it's like that level of like
but
you know to me like family it's he's
even more than family mart because you
can find family mart all over asia it's
it's it's like it's like all over asia
so greg that yeah yeah there's like
family marts in thailand actually
like i don't know either but this is
news to me yeah yeah yeah exactly so
it's it's not like a specific it's it's
obviously very japanese like i'm gonna
assume it started in japan but it's like
expanded but like i believe greg's is
only available in the uk right and it's
it's nothing
so there's like a real like british
prize yeah yeah so it's cheap it tastes
amazing um
yeah what's next sausage rolls man why
aren't you guys taking me there i want
to go i actually haven't seen any it's
like the hype is so real in my yeah like
not only have you guys like hyped it up
but like literally every second british
person i met this weekend is like greg's
though
the nearest greg's yeah real [ __ ]
yeah get get your boy some greg and then
there were people being like yo so like
have you been at tesco's yet like have
you had the tesco meal deal yeah not yet
and
i knew like it was like real [ __ ]
because like people were like all right
here's my recommendation
these are the ones to avoid these are
the ones that you should go for and i i
didn't realize there were so many
different meal deals and like there were
people like in the signing right there
would be like a person in front of me
being like all right so here's the meal
deal i recommend and i knew it was real
[ __ ] when like the person behind them
would like interject and be like
don't don't don't don't give me don't
spread misinformation yeah yeah yeah
this is the real [ __ ] and i was just
like guys chill out
though there's greg's ten minutes away
from him [ __ ] yeah what's going on
but yeah i mean like i mean like we talk
about tesco meal deals but a meal deal
is like a lot of choice so you need to
like have the optimal order right yeah i
mean there's just like there's like it's
it's like blackjack that's the perfect
way to play it you know that's what a
meal deal is right so you need to you
need to learn how to count cards okay
pick the right meal deal because you
know there's certain items in the meal
deal that you can get where if you were
to buy them individually it would cost
like two pound fifty right so you can
kind of min max the price options right
yeah so don't be buying water don't get
like you know uh [ __ ] little fruit
thing get maximize your your cost
performance yeah you don't wanna go for
walkers crisps mccoy's crisps the big
boys as well
or walkers max walker's man you can't
just go like the little [ __ ] basic
ass vanilla get like an innocent
smoothie as well then i'm like two
pounds
every person at the same time it's
i knew it was real [ __ ] as well because
there was like a bunch of people also
like when they mentioned the tesco meal
deal they were like they came up to me
and they were like yeah you know tesco
meal deals are amazing but they opted by
50p and it's an absolute [ __ ]
travesty and i'm just like i wish i
could feel your anger right now because
it seems very real right there's one
like one minute walk not even one minute
like it's literally opposite our hotel
oh [ __ ] yeah so yeah yeah there's
usually there was this article in the uk
uh that some doctor was calling for meal
deals to be banned because they're too
unhealthy
really and they're too like
appealing yeah because they're still
feeling because people people just buy
these like every day for lunch because
it's such good value for money and they
taste [ __ ] amazing but they're really
bad for you because the sandwiches are
like absolutely like
just stuffed with awful stuff yeah yeah
but it's like a mcdonald's burger it's
like you don't want to know what goes in
but you know it tastes so bad it tastes
good right yeah why does it taste so
damn good what does ronald put in those
are exactly the same as all right oh
yeah they're like like you know the
sandwiches are like not fresh at all but
like yeah but they still taste good they
taste really funny yeah i mean i guess
it's like talking going back to like why
people are recommending you what to
order it's kind of like going to like
you know a chinese dress from here
ordering like kung pao chicken or
something like i've had chinese food and
then you know everyone would be like no
you have not had chinese food you know
and i mean it's like you know
expressive yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly
yeah no you like i'm not even the meal
deal guy but if you go if you're gonna
try one out joey at least try like the
optimal meal deal
and then we can have a real experience
and then we can argue about it you know
yeah
some of the sandwiches come with an
additional slice oh just for free like
just out of the general it's not like a
secret menu or anything no no no no no
there's like because normally it's like
you don't have to say like a code word
normally it's like two slices but some
of them for some reason they have like
one sandwich and a half in it and no one
knows why
it's one of the great mysteries of the
world it's like they're like just trying
to figure it out if you've like truly
optimized them yeah like if you're if
you're a real player yeah i don't know
that's how you go through like
everything in the menu you know so you
so you you know the good [ __ ] i've had
i've had a pot noodle yet [ __ ] i want to
have a bombay bad boy partner is that
like the
cup noodle there yeah
dude the spicy one is so good it smells
so good well i'd see i want to
experience this all right all right yeah
i guess i guess i guess
i'm just scared that you might not like
the stuff and i'll be like this is
literally my entire existence is waiting
on this like if you don't if you don't
if you don't like this i'm gonna die
i mean look there's a lot of food that
is considered awful that i absolutely
enjoy so i mean how bad are you going
famous last words how bad could it be
you gotta be honest joey you gotta be
honest you know we wouldn't be the trash
taste podcast if we weren't honest i
keep forgetting how [ __ ] mayo is as well
huh i keep forgetting how bad yeah i've
i've gone back to not eating mayo i i i
had one sandwich because like japan has
conditioned me to be like mayo tastes
good
yeah
i always forget i'm just like i just
assume everywhere it has cupid
mayonnaise yeah it's like oh no that
that was like a delicacy
should have brought your own that's like
some real [ __ ] yeah yeah i i've kind of
like come to this realization because i
did like i i did it's a small tangent
but before the boys came here i did go
on like uh
go on like a
quick trip to like belgium
um and i ate
a lot of bread oh oh i i i ate a lot of
i'm awake now basically every [ __ ]
meal i ordered the meal and i'd get a
loaf of bread and it wasn't like the
same look like
a little bun no no no i'm not talking
about that it's like loaf i think they
they basically gave me half a like
i swear to god every [ __ ] meal like
even if it wasn't a meal even if i
ordered a drink with like some quick
snacks and they just give you bread
belgian belgium knows what's up dude
yeah yeah yeah so like brett
i think i like bread
that's character development right there
i i i want to do a proper like bread
tasting stream or something like
actually try proper bread because like i
i kind of realized that maybe my entire
life i didn't have [ __ ] taste maybe my
entire life i just grew up in a place
that just had [ __ ] food yes
that was like [ __ ] forever
you could get good bread in the uk you
just didn't see each other you just need
to like seek it out where it's just like
it's it you know you have to go to like
specialty places it's so good which is
like which is like true for a lot of
like cuisine in the uk which is like you
can't get good stuff here what you just
have to seek it out wait so what's your
favorite bread now
like your favorite kind i don't know i
don't know i just tried a lot of bread
and they all tasted amazing i i i need
to get more in i i need to get more uh i
[ __ ] performed on bread man i just
i'm just like i just got given bread i'm
like i want bread my man's finally
getting that bread
when they give you bread and they give
you like a little [ __ ] uh olive oil
kind of dip thing with like yeah i like
the balsamic
oh don't mind if i do yeah oh yeah oh
yeah
i love bread so much every time i go to
like an italian restaurant in the states
thank you like that bread with the olive
oil and the bell samming i'm like [ __ ]
the pasta just give me more of this [ __ ]
it's so good
oh i guess i just got a text from god
wait god just found new waifu
[Music]
um
[Music]
i'm gonna have to check this game out
now oh my god this video is sponsored by
data live spirit pledge hd so make sure
you smash the link in the description
down below to get a chance to play this
awesome game get a chance to have a
fight with your new waifu and maybe have
a romantic date with her so go and press
that link in the description down below
and yes that was a sponsored group chat
section fellow generates i think
spending money in england is way too
easy
bro yeah just tapping that card yeah
it's like monopoly so like i know the us
has contactless japan has contactless
but like
in the form of suica no no one you can't
use that like restaurants and stuff
right it's it's for like other places
yeah it is getting better though too
yeah yeah because like a lot of i i did
notice that a lot of places because like
in australia as well now it's like
everything is just like yeah yeah yeah
dude i mean like in the uk now it just
seems to be that like the default is now
the tapping the credit card yeah yeah
and it's way too easy to spend a lot of
money yeah yeah just something pops up
you're like i don't even know how much
it is [ __ ] tap and then you're like
i'm broke now [ __ ] because like i
remember like the the first time like
they they bring that out right and they
just kind of like hand it to you it's
like
i was because i'm so used to doing it in
japan right so i pulled my phone out to
like get my suitca ready right and i was
just like nope that's not it that's it's
credit card it's credit card i think you
could do with your phone now if you had
the right things yeah right and it's
like and and because you know i'm so
used to like even in japan when you do
like the whole tapping thing yeah like
not only can you see how much money
you've spent but it's also like there's
a little bit of a process right yeah
like you know kind of get it going but
yeah in the uk it's literally just
and you're done yeah yeah because
because a lot a lot of the times uh
because with contactless here they like
it's they have like a specific device
for contact lists or they'll like show
you the side with the contactless on
yeah uh and it's not decided with the
price on so you don't even know how much
is that yeah exactly exactly like i i've
realized after coming back this time
they've increased the limit again yeah
so when first contactless started coming
out i believe the limit was like 20 when
when i was at 20.
and then it got really increased to 30
and then i believe 40. and i was like
80. we we just [ __ ] doubled the
amount with a single tap of your card
you can spend 100 bucks you know that's
so scary like
i realized how dangerous this was
because at the convention uh i was like
buying i was like buying a round of
drinks um
and uh i didn't like i normally in japan
they at least they tell you the price
right they tell you the price of how
much you're spending and here they don't
even tell you the price they just assume
you know the price and they they they
give you the contact thing and you beep
it so i i bring back i bring back the
drinks and i remember one of my friends
asked me oh was uh are the drinks
expensive here and i would just go
yeah i didn't know
maybe
so i feel like yes is the answer but i
don't know yeah and then and they're
like
i say i think it's probably expensive
and they'll and they're like no no is it
london expensive or is it london hotel
expensive and i was just like
yes yes
yes either one of those yeah
i probably have to ask how much drinks
are but right now i literally have no
idea i just tapped my wallet away i
literally don't know how much i've spent
while i've been here just because again
they don't tell you yeah it's so easy
it's literally just like throwing
monopoly money out true true being like
yeah cool okay that was easy sweet and
then it's only when you get back to the
hotel and you're like oh [ __ ] i wish it
was monopoly money because at least with
monopoly money you kind of like know how
much you're spending you're like you
know i keep tracking my monopoly money
i spend it very carefully
yeah because it's scary i remember like
um
because we went to we
we we had a night and we ended up just
like quickly just like as a group mates
in the casino right and so
uh we didn't you know we didn't play
that much but you know i played a little
bit and i ended up with some some like
physical money on me at the end of the
night right and i remember like cashing
out getting this physical money in my
wallet and i was like this is useless
when am i ever going to spend this when
am i ever going to spend this physical
money that they've given me right and
because you don't ever need to spend
like cash at all yeah i noticed yeah
yeah so now it's just like a paperweight
in my [ __ ] wallet
suffering from
success it's not even it's like what am
i going to do with all this money this
is just suffering from convenience
it is suffering from convenience that
we've gotten to now oh my god yeah but
yeah i guess that's been our return to
the uk yeah it's been great it's been
great it's been absolutely amazing thank
you for carrying this episode i've been
like
dead for some reason i think jet lag is
still kicking my ass yeah it is a video
it's also really warm in this studio
yeah yeah it's so hot i feel like i'm in
a sauna yeah it's like lecture warm yeah
at least in like japan we have an air
conditioner yeah yeah yeah in the years
yeah i was like in my head i was like
can we turn the aircon on and i was
looking around briefly
where where is it where is it help
uh but hey look at all these patrons
though yeah look at all these lovely
pages i forgot that we needed a shower
but it doesn't even feel like trash
taste no that feels weird honestly like
i was so excited to have like the boys
come over because we haven't we haven't
recorded the trash taste in like i feel
like a month three weeks yeah almost a
month i think i'm not even not only that
but normally at least like i'm in japan
or something but you know i'd come to
the uk early to finalize my wedding
stuff so i was just like here and i was
just like not talking to the boys not
recording trash taste and i was just
like when i saw them come to england it
was just i don't know it just felt it
just felt yes it felt it feels nice to
have the boys back man oh yeah reunited
yeah it's good to be back yeah i like it
oh yeah but hopefully you enjoyed this
episode hey if you want to support the
show then go over to our patreon
patreon.com also follow us on twitter
send us some memes on the subreddit and
if you hate our face listen to us on
spotify and uh we're going to be here
for
next couple of episodes two or two
months
yeah two more episodes and then we're
gonna be in a completely different
location who knows what will be next but
uh yeah hopefully you guys enjoy it and
we'll see you in the next one all right
bye
[Music]
you